j'ai attendu j'ai attendu et 1h 2h 3h et
à la fin il s'est barré il est même
passé et c'est bien parce qu'on a eus
l'anecdote on temps réel alors il ya une
vidéo qui à propos de céline dion vous
allez voir comment la star aurait traité
une de ses fans qui les faisait une
démonstration de chant et là c'est vrai
que là moi ça m'a ça parce que moi je se
fout de ces lignes non mais vraiment et
là vous avez vu la vidéo la photo
téléspectateur va nous dire ce qui
choque ans après regardez
[Musique]
ces phases
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce qu'il a fait ce qu'il y'a pas
moi aussi j'adore chez hyper triste de
ce qu'elle a fait est ce que c'est par
les ménages
ol sur cette vidéo est un fait il s'agit
d'un montage on va tout de suite regardé
la vidéo originale le premier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors là on en rigole mais ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que ces millions a été très
affectée par tous les commentaires qui a
eu dans la part des gens ont cru que je
t'embrasse
c'est l'accent qu'elle en plus si on
dirait pas et que je te le dis que je
viendrais bien tu as mené d orignal au
canada contre la brasse et que tu
devrais je sais déjà
est-ce qu'il ya une star qui vous a déjà
déçu vous ah ouais vous par exemple qui
a way julia roberts jude la robert
valérie quand j'étais à célébrités on
m'avait envoyé à new york ça une
interview de julia roberts j'étais comme
un fou ah ouais pour vraiment il ya plus
habiles et donne les moyens bihan
concorde et caetera et je suis arrivé
j'avais vingt minutes de prévu et quand
je suis arrivé là-bas pour l'interview
elle m'a dit je voudrais cinq minutes
non là j'ai pété un plomb j mais
franchement vous traitez les gens
commençaient impossible et on s'est dit
ça julia roberts et rendu les images on
s'est engueulés c'est un scandale
mais s'ils étaient moins con tout le
monde à tous les vêtements j'ai fait un
petit bout chacun est comme ça fait une
étable condensé jc c'est un scandale
madame non je les insulte est out
insultes et julia roberts of kings
moi ce que je kiffe ce que je kiffe dans
l'histoire c'est que tu as pris le
concorde alors le concours existe plus
génial quand le seul moyen de prendre le
concorde aujourd'hui elle est allée dans
le sindh au logis
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais l'animal est pas déçu moi c'est une
rencontre loupé avec bruce willis non
extrêmement déçu bruce willis oui pareil
pour c'est sûr et bruce willis était pas
bruce qui pis est menée à paris à
l'époque vous savez il est il avait mis
de l'argent dans planet hollywood et
mais qui venaient à paris la croire que
oui
business - chanteur il avait un absolu
mais il venait et donc pour
l'inauguration du panneau hollywood
il venait faire un mini concert et donc
moi j'avais obtenu pour tf1 les
l'interview de bruce willis ont et il
était sur scène et qui fait kiffer qu'il
fait et donc qu il continue à chanter et
ils arrêtaient pas dire pour la
journaliste on attend qu'elles attendent
qu'elle attend de calage de vous la
journaliste s'était moyenne annuelle
attendent qu'elles attendent que tu
achètes presse était hyper emmerder j'ai
attendu j'ai attendu et 1h 2h 3h et à la
fin il s'est barré il est même précéder
ses précédents c'est bien parce qu'on a
eus l'anecdote on temps réel ça sert
serra c'est très rare d'avoir ça qui a
déjà été ainsi on a loupé bruce willis
aussi exactement pour la même raison
c'est le même soir
c'est sûrement aidé mickey rooney qui
nous a demandé s'il avait senti quelque
chose c'était pas moi jean-michel non
merci de kung fu plus personne aucun
invité de la semaine un invité pmp quand
on dit frais si ricco reconcile freddy
ah oui évidemment et après après
l'émission en loges en tant que
professionnel on s'est un peu mon
traîneau et lui l'était il pleurait pas
excellent et l'autre la casinière kitty
crowther
vas-y airs sur l'île aux enfants
[Musique]